[Music] the world has gotten even stranger than
you already know at this point I doubt anything
would surprise me ten bucks says you're wrong what
you think Pilates was these guys come from legend
they're basically gods there's only one God man
and I'm pretty sure he doesn't dress like that and
I'd like to know how Loki used it to turn two of
the sharpest men I know into his personal flying
monkeys don't understand I do I understood that
reference you're not going alone you stopped me
put on the suit let's find out I'm not afraid to
hit that man put on the suit that stator control
unit can reverse the polarity long enough to
disengage maglev and that's just dunk foods a
lot better we used to boil everything no polios
good internet so helpful been reading that a lot
trying to catch up Marvin Gaye 1972 Trouble
Man soundtrack everything you missed jammed
into one out I'll put it on the list you know
they used to play music yeah where did Captain
America learn hands still car Nazi Germany and
we're borrowing take your feet off the dash
without your first kiss since 1945 that bad
huh I didn't say that well it kind of sounds
like that's what you're saying no I didn't
I just wondered how much practice you had
don't need prayer everybody needs practice
without my first kiss since 1945 I'm 95 I'm
not dead language no one else is gonna deal
with the fact that cap just said language I
know gosh sake watch your language as maybe
the world's leading authority on waiting too
long don't outwit the Platinum bastard Steve
doesn't like that kind of talk you know what
Romanov fury son of a [__] whoa you kiss
your mother with that mouth it's pepper I
didn't say we're kind of well not kind of
pregnant no definitely not what was her name
again Dolores you called her doc she's gotta
be a hundred years old right now so are we pal
I went in the ice in 45 right after I met the
love of my life who here hasn't been to space
you better not throw up on my ship time travel
what I can do this all day yeah I know I know
maybe I'll try some of that life Tony was
telling me to give you want to tell me
about her no no I don't think I will
[Music]